capcom has announced that Akuma will be
the next character to join street
fighter 5 s roster of fighters I'm Lucy
and welcome to your power made flesh
gamespot news update Akuma was announced
after the conclusion of the red bull
battlegrounds tournament in Seattle a
teaser video was shown during the event
which also revealed a new stage which is
a rainy backdrop that has a dilapidated
temple in the distance Akuma is shown
executing his raging demon move so is
depicted as a blood-red I darting around
in the dark as the sounds of punches and
kicks could be hurt Japanese Kanji
suddenly appears superimposed onto the
characters back completing the iconic
pose fans have noted that the kanji
symbol is different from the one usually
seen on a kumas back and in fact it's
closer to the one used for capcom vs SNK
2 ordinarily the kanji is a reference to
heaven but this time it means God
according to event hubs this is like
some speculation on how he may play
specifically in regards to what his be
trigger activation could be the current
thinking is that it could allow him to
transform into Shin Akuma and enter a
more powerful state much like Macaulay
although Capcom has not yet announced a
release date for Akuma the character
will be playable at PlayStation
experience this event is set to take
place at the anaheim convention center
on december third and fourth so what do
you think of the new edition is it too
little too late for street fighter 5 or
are you still playing let me know in the
comments below or come by me on Twitter
I met Lucy James games for more on
Street Fighter make sure you keep it
gamespot
you